oui le président zelensky et ne veut
peut-être pas à nommer les localités
mais la bataille la plus intense ce qui
semble s'être soldé par une victoire a
eu lieu au autour de ballack l'ia qui
est une ville au nord ouest de zoom dans
la dans le sud de la région de harkis
vivent je ne sais pas si vous avez une
carte sur l'écran ou si vous l'avez en
tête mais ce que les forces ukrainiennes
sont en train d'essayer de faire c'est
de pousser vers le nord-est et donc de
couper idiome qui est dans le sud de la
région de l'arctique juste avant
l'audience a tenu à parler russe et de
pousser vers la ville de kouqian ce qui
est plus dans le nord-est de cette
région de archives c'est une contre
offensive surprise en quelque sorte les
ukrainiens avaient annoncé leur contre
offensive dans le sud dont la région de
personnes mais il n'avait pas beaucoup
parlé de la région d'un art qui va alors
est-ce que ils ont vu une opportunité
puisque les russes avaient déployé
beaucoup de forces pour défendre la
région des personnes dans le sud ou
parce que c'était cela toujours le plan
le sujet fait débat mais en tout cas ce
sont des succès que les ukrainiens ont
remporté qui sont confirmées par les
experts ukrainiens
excusez moi les experts américains à
l'institut des études de la guerre à
washington qui disent même que l'ukraine
aurait repris quelques 400 kilomètres
carrés dans la région de harkis gulliver
bonjour quelles sont les informations
dont vous disposez en ce qui concerne
les autres fronts notamment celui de ray
ressort
alors d'abord dans la région demerson la
contre-offensive continue mais il semble
clair que les batailles à sont raisins
sont intenses et qu'il y à des pertes
importantes des deux côtés les
ukrainiens ne veulent pas annoncer la
prise de localités
il semblerait qu'ils reprennent du
terrain mais tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que c'est très difficile et que
c'est une contre offensive qui va
prendre plusieurs semaines et puis ici
où je me trouve dans le dos de basse il
n'y a pas de contre offensive à propre
on peut appeler à une contre offensive
dont le duo basse mais ce qui se passe
selon les soldats à qui j'ai pu par mais
hier c'est que les russes en plus ou
moins arrêter d'avancer c'est vrai
qu'ils ont pris récemment le village de
peace qui jusqu'au nord de la ville de
donetsk mais sinon leur tentative de
prendre des villes comme bach mouthe par
exemple semble être à l'arrêt les
soldats hier m'ont dit que si il y a
quelques semaines il avancé par colonne
de tanks très nombreuses maintenant
s'ils essayent de faire des percées sur
deux terrains c'est vraiment par des
très petites unités qui sont assez
faciles pour les ukrainiens repoussé
mais ces soldats m'ont tout de même dit
que l'artillerie continue à les
bombarder et que dans la région de
donetsk en tout cas les forces
ukrainiens ne sont vraiment pas en
position de pouvoir monter une
contre-offensive en ce moment tout ce
qu'ils peuvent faire c'est défendre mais
il défendre bien ils ne perdent pas
vraiment de terrain merci